will the person who's never been on a
date please step
forward I think Marie in the beginning
was trying to throw me off sounds like
she's a really mature outlook on what
she wants in a relationship and she
really knows herself so I feel like
she's really like explored that part of
herself with Octavia I feel like she
also really knows herself and knows what
she wants I feel like Kayla was also
trying to fake me out a she came in hot
she was like I don't care about dating
whatever there was all friends to lovers
pipelines Joanne she did did mention
first date and dates a few different
times and then Jenna when she did
describe the date she had been on it was
like a restaurant and a barade and there
wasn't more detail to it so my guest for
who hasn't been on a date is Jenna will
the person who's never been on a date
please step
forward
oh yeah that's just hasn't been a part
of my life yet at all so